so this game was another Sicilian and
NIM actually played a variation called
it's called the pin variation which is
considered to be bad and you actually
reacted very well so he played Bishop
before mm-hmm and I was watching the
game and getting concerned about how you
would react here and you actually
reacted correctly e5 and NIM took on c3
with his Bishop which is a huge cop-out
the way that this pin variation actually
goes is 94 and this is a losing line for
black but if white does not know how to
refute this you can probably see how
dangerous this could be right no
absolutely I'm gonna show you the
reputation because it's just really
really cool and there's some beautiful
ideas there
[Music]
so the correct move here is queen g4
which looks like a humungous blunder
right because if Knight takes c3 and
what happens if you take the knight he
takes back at the check he wins a rook
yeah so what the hell are we doing and
not only that to add insult to injury
this is like a discovery situation here
but we actually take on g7 of the Queen
we ignore everything and the idea is if
he moves this night away what is the
best way for us to block the discovered
check do we break it with our bishop
because pushing that pawn gives us the
same problem doesn't it and what problem
is that
he still takes it with his knight and
Bishop holds that pin one's a rook yeah
except you seem to have an aversion for
taking ropes that are on the Kings side
like you didn't take a rook on G now you
don't take it work on F h8i
I see alright alright I guess I got a
little too concerned with defense Jesus
yeah so let me just tell you something
I'm gonna give you a warning
if ever there will be a rook on f8 that
you might be able to take I'm gonna give
you one more chance at redemption you
better take it right because you didn't
take it on H a you didn't take it on G a
now but that's purely hypothetical
situation because you'll never encounter
a situation like that so you go c3 does
that make sense now you're attacking the
rook you're attacking the bishop yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so black actually believe it or not has
to go rook f8 now you make the move a3
which makes you know it makes sense once
you look at this move cuz you're
attacking the bishop you're attacking
the base of the discovery Bishop has to
go back to a5 in order to preserve sorry
in order to preserve the defense tonight
if the bishop goes elsewhere
thank you mermaid for the gift you take
the knight no harm at all and we've
destroyed blacks King side so is that
making sense so far I know I'm going
pretty fast that makes sense this seems
pretty simple stuff so far yeah it's it
nothing you know nothing terribly
complicated even tactically and now
you actually make the move Bishop to h6
which and and what are you threatening
and please answer this correctly I'm
threatening to take that rook on f8
which also happens to be a checkmate
you actually didn't say Queen takes h7
I'm very impressed
I would never that pawn on h7 design
register on my radio I've never taken
that point when you could have taken
rook instead ever I've literally never
even looked at that h7 pawn I forgot
there's even an H file read this guy's
discuss it was a repulsive so black is
only one defense here which is Queen e7
the really elegant thing here is if he
tries to move his knight away first -
you know sneak off with a bishop how do
you and this is a very similar theme to
something you're familiar with how do
you defend against this check because
remember you're attacking the rook so
you can pose another threat here and win
material so when I was looking at is
bringing the Bishop to g5 well that
would be great so many lower levels I
don't even know where to start if you if
you were already missing that this is a
check then at least say quintals FA
checkmate where's that pollen move that
I told you to make where's my b4 pawn
move I told you to make all right there
before yeah yeah and then you met Bishop
g5 after that yeah so yeah you weren't
keeping up with what I was saying yeah I
missed that move somewhere between I
missed that letter between a and B but
before the ideas checkmate and if Queen
Queen let's say guards the rook what do
you do you just taking bishop and then
we'll get to what you do next so let's
say the black plays Queen e7 here
defending the rook
now you go Knight to b3 another
beautiful move attacking the bishop look
at how you're like dealing with the base
of this discovery the knight is under
attack but you're simultaneously
attacking the bishop
Bishop has to move you take the knight
and now I want you to tell me the final
move of this entire sequence this is all
like theory this has all been studied
before
thank you so much this is how this line
plays out every time then basically this
is why the pin variation is considered
refuted but this next move is one that I
have a feeling you might have some
difficulty with is it just good looking
for this checkmate so we're gonna try
and distract the Queen by throwing like
the knight over here it's c-5s or
something that's not a dumb idea I
promise I can take the knight and I'm
still making contact with the rook yeah
so that's yeah believe it or not and
this is not an entirely something you're
familiar with you can't take the rook
and can you tell me what happens at the
end of this trade like who is up white
I'll give you a pass on this particular
instance of taking the rook on FA it's
because we're up of the rook right now
so we're a plus three according to the
game which is an exchange we're up in
exchange I think I've introduced you to
that concept right yeah okay I guess
it's just a little apprehensive about
taking something like that but going
bishop for rook makes sense right
essentially the Queen trade is part of
the package but what you're really doing
remove the Queens from the equation
you're given Bishop four rook which is
very much favorable for you so anyways
that is a long-winded explanation but
that's just to show you how far opening
theory has been developed like all this
[ __ ] that 50 years ago someone could
have played this variation like 10-15
years in a row in scored countless
victories then computers came along none
of this works anymore so chess has
changed completely
but named actually took the knight on c3
and in the context of what I just
explained you'll have a much easier time
now finding the way that you could have
punished him name goes 94 you are
basically winning here immediately if
you find the right move
yeah so now I'm just immediately going
with my queen right I'm going to g4 with
my queen bingo Knight takes c3 finish me
off yes and now I'm just bringing this
bad boy all the way up there to g7 he
goes through at the f8 and instead of
Bishop h6 which allows this move Queen
e7
which somehow keeps black in the game
you have another way of attacking this
rook which ends the game on the spot
because I was just bringing my bishop
over a three and black and resigned he
literally has to give up an entire Queen
in order to stave off checkmate so
that's how quickly this game could have
ended but in your mind what you were
seeing is the attack on the c3 pawn so
we were talking all this time about
tunnel vision with stuff like tactics
but the time has come for you when you
see a threat against one of your pawns
your default almost should be to ignore
it pawns are meant to be sacrificed like
if it's a threat on your piece find that
should be your top priority but a measly
little worthless runt of upon like c3
especially when he's not developed your
default here should already be to look
for counter blows against his King and
to err on the side of over sacrificing
if that makes sense yeah that makes
sense okay yeah so from this position
there really is not a whole lot he can
play right so even if he pushes that
pawn up there to prevent this rook
potential checkmate and then I win a
knight yeah like an entirely winning
position it's completely winning
probably the lesser evil is actually to
give up the knight but it's not just the
knight he's giving up look at these dark
squares you could do what you did with
them in the in the last game and bring
your knight there and stick it right up
his gut I mean this position is not only
is he down at pcs he doesn't even have
anything to show for it okay that makes
sense yeah I would not have seen this
progression here because yeah I'm pretty
sure in the game I brought bishop to d2
right to protect the hanging piece right
exactly well whereas they say what did
what did the disappointed driver say
when he he lost a piece and he didn't
have any compensation he didn't have
anything to show for it
chauffer chauffer okay that's great
that was a really good joke yo they're
mean oh I didn't know there was a joke
in there I thought you were giving like
some kind of age-old adage on chess
I just read that on reddit jokes and I
repurposed it to Jess which I usually
wear what I do with my jokes
okay I see you'll have to hit me with
that one again when it's not like a
chess situation so I could recognize the
humor in it i I think that he like I
couldn't I actually have tried to make a
more smoother joke of it like it's show
show for and like chauffeur that's like
the idea of the fun one being a play on
words like as in a word that sounds like
another word anyways yeah chess jokes
are universally unfunny I think I don't
think I've ever heard of funny Chester I
know some chest jokes that are nerdy
where like you have to know chess to
appreciate it
let me try to tell one more and redeem
myself because your chat is probably
disowning me right now let me redeem
myself so hit it hit him in order to
understand this joke you need to know
who Capablanca was casablanca was a rule
capablanca was a world champion from
cuba that's all you need to know about
him there's one other thing you need to
know about him which is at the time that
the joke is being delivered kappa blanka
is dead okay the joke begins when two
masters are talking to old friends who
are both chess masters one of them is
dead and the one who's alive sees the
one who's dead in his dreams and he's
like man so how is it in heaven do you
get to play chess and the dead one was
like yeah you know we have all these
tournaments and man I even got to play
all these world champions and the friend
was alive and dreaming says man that's
awesome and the dead guy says yeah it
really is you actually have a game with
kappa blanka said in 20 minutes yeah i
don't know if anybody just got that I
think everything leading up to the joke
was significantly better than the actual
the actual punchline but the actual meat
of it yeah well the suggestion being
that he's gonna be dead you think be
dead soon
yeah that's like most just that is an
epitome of like the inside of the mind
of most chess players okay well I
actually think a lot of people are like
laughing because it's so
name that it actually is funny there is
a certain threshold where a joke can be
like such a [ __ ] stinker that that in
and of itself is some great rumor yeah I
think you're a extent horizon I have
mastered that particular art yeah you're
a GM in that department I am I
absolutely am wonderful that was
everybody's just that's all people are
gonna be thinking about is how great
that was Daniel's execution of the real
banger yeah actually I think the
funniest jokes I know are not chest
jokes unfortunately so I'm really making
a great advertisement for this world of
chess
so anyways um back to this game he takes
on c3 it goes 94 so Bishop d2 is classic
tunnel vision you pay attention to this
pawn and you make this little you know
this is the kind of like move you would
make if you if you had a keep Tahoe blue
a little sticker on your laptop in 2007
like no you know you want to play queen
chief or anyway so nem takes the bishop
as he as he should and he kind of won't
actually no he doesn't he castles you go
f3 takes takes I'm just gonna go fast
and again sorry I'm manually inputting
the moves now knight c6 here you
blundered upon which how should you have
defended this point you play Bishop d3
by the way okay yeah I should've just
brought the pawn up right there for
exactly and my greatest compliment to
you of all time is about to arrive so I
want to prepare yourself if you need any
lubricants brought to you or paper
towels assembled let me know I'm happy I
can't wait but it is it is about to
write first of all this stretch where
you played the move f4 which I loved you
came up with the idea of the rock lift
at this point I was streaming and
watching this game and I was like ok
Charlie should probably lift the rock up
but I don't know if she's gonna see this
idea because it involves pushing the
pawn out at that very moment you said
those exact same things then NIM brings
his Queen to h4
and this is the one moment where you
faltered a little bit you played the
move g3 so what I want you to understand
here is a queen alone looks intimidating
but it's actually a huge liability this
is what most beginners don't understand
they bring their Queens out to try to
intimidate their opponents into
submission you know into not
accomplishing their plan but it actually
makes the plan stronger so let's examine
what would happen if you still lifted
your rook up head does his queen stop
your rope from reaching h3 no it only
encourages it right because network h3
comes with tempo and it attacks the
Queen yeah so remember if your opponent
brings his queen out in order to try to
stop something you're doing chances are
it only makes it worse
and his queen becomes a huge liability
which it became in the game as well you
play g3 queen g4 Knight f3 which was you
know all decent h6 King G to b6 h3 and
the great move this is probably the
finest move of your chest career comes
here where you played the move Queen f2
to find g4 so yeah baby
how's this my idea like you at first you
were gonna play g4 and trap his queen
but you saw that it hung the night but
you didn't abandon this idea which is
what it would be so easy to do this is
actually an amazing move Queen f2
preparing to four and it paid off
because and then immediately faltered
what would have been if you flip the
board you can flip the board if you want
what would have been blacks best way to
prevent that like if you wanted to save
his queen and save a piece yeah the only
way you'd be able to do that those by
pushing that pawn on f7 right so you can
drop the Queen back exactly f6 or f5 now
let's continue our positional training
let's say he plays out five what square
in the center of the board is this move
weakened yeah now I have C six nothing
is defending it except the bishop so if
I can get the bishop to move at some
point or relinquish its control there
that I can take that position yeah but
asks you for a square not a pawn
you're right a six is weakened but
there's a square associated with these
six that's also weak Oh over there on g6
you're right by art by the by definition
g6 is a weak but I'm looking more in the
center weak squares are most important
in the center where if you occupied them
that's actually good for something okay
so then it's just e five then and how
can you bring the appropriate piece to
that square do I have to bring my knight
over here to f3 first to prep that and
then take that position at E 5 at me no
that's exactly what you do
that's a maneuver yeah it sounds
intimidating but all it is is taking a
piece that's on a shoe T Square and
putting it on a piece putting it on a
great square so the knight on h4 has
done its job
you have provoked a weakness and now you
bring the knight around to the best
possible square so you were at a stage
where oftentimes when you don't know
what to do which is most of the time but
that's ok one question you could ask
yourself to facilitate this situation is
can I identify any of my pieces that are
not doing anything or are not serving to
the best of their potential and actually
improve their placement in by improve
their placement what I mean is if
there's a particular square on the board
where you can realistically bring this
piece you try to chart a course and you
see if it takes you a realistic amount
of moves to get the piece there at this
stage of your chest development not
everything you're gonna do is gonna take
what I've told you this before some
stuff you do is gonna take more than one
move including maneuvers so does that
kind of strike you as reasonable that
makes sense but instead name mal slips
at this point he could have taken the
pawn and at least kept his losses to a
piece but he gifted you this yeah that's
what I said that during the stream as
well was that an accident when he took
that
I couldn't tell by his fish I watched
his face like you could never tell and
maybe the check-in inform us I don't
know maybe they were watching his stream
I would imagine it is because it's
that's a hard thing to miss or maybe he
was so rattled by gee for the the genius
of that that he just lost his fin he
actually did no he did not and he didn't
he didn't think that you were capable of
such an idea so he thought there must be
a flaw in it because he didn't see it
yeah apparently he just didn't see it
well so anyways what I wanted to say
about this game is what really bothered
me was your technique in this position
like you really struggled through this
and that is sort of what brought me to
say I think we need more work on your
technique because watch essentially what
happens ug5 is great your checkmating
him and already at this point you could
have ended the game with in three moves
so when you have a situation with
position from this position when you
have a situation like this in your mind
you need to have what's called a target
position you already need to be
envisioning which kind of check maker
probably going to deliver whereas in
your minds I felt like you kept toggling
between different types of ideas and you
couldn't settle on one particular way of
winning again don't mean to put words in
your mouth but at least from how you
were playing and how you were thinking I
felt like that was the case so this
Queen on h6 what is it accomplishing
right now it's cutting off his escape
here on H the H file I'm attacking this
pawn on f4 if I could I could start
looking to get the rook down there as
well to deliver a chair to get him off
that and then deliver a check on h8 and
when his rook on 8th or checkmate in my
knight shape because that would also be
checkmate so but forget about the pawn
on f4 again remember you've had your
your buffet dinner like you're up a
goddamn queen like who gives a damn
about this pawn you know what I'm saying
I can
I want to finish this game and end it I
don't care about collecting plots if you
keep your queen on h6 which restricts
all of his squares
could you use one of your works to
deliver checkmate and I'm talking about
target positions here in the ideal
scenario where could you put your rook
on which file for example more age now
now I see that that's a checkmate yeah
getting my rook over to h1 and then
pushing the Queen there's another file
he could get your rook on to without
even pushing your queen getting it to
the G file to look to attack the King
that way and then bring the rook down
over there now in the context of that do
you see how bad your move King g1
actually is because it blocks both of
those things from happening so we're
sure yeah we're sure you have like put
your King in order I should have brought
it up 3 right bingo he can give you
exactly one check and you do what yeah
no I just want to take the pawn right
take a boy you're threatening checkmate
yeah he has to play rook e6 and now from
this position I want you to make the
moves and I want you to finish me off in
the fastest possible way playing white
thanks for the three boxer manga you
seem amused discombobulated and he tells
that you can deliver its uh delivering
the check at g1 he blocks with his rook
at g6 do it though your bubble queen
which means you just need to clear
everything around blacks King just take
the rook really that's the that's the
correct progression it is but look at
his King now use your other rook and
like bring it to I mean this move should
come intuitively like where does this
work on a 1b long AE one right here or I
mean how about if you were trying to
give me like a ladder checkmate then I
could put it all the way over here a G
and drop the Queen but alright no H
Jesus my Queens yeah exactly
h1 so go rock h1 so I think the problem
is you keep trying to find the
mathematically fastest mate whereas when
I say the word fastest I essentially
mean the easiest you know the one that
you can play play the fastest let's say
I go rook t8y and then I'm just
immediately doing a letter it's a no I'm
just coming all the way down here going
to look for the check no you don't need
to this king is not going anywhere you
have it cornered so just to set up
mating squares yeah so then I need to
just go over here on h7 first right to
set that up
exactly yeah that's it he can't swell he
can make this genius defensive move but
what are you gonna do you take the rook
take the rook and then give check me so
you see how easy that was and all you
really have to do like this move
surprises you because I feel like you
create this rigid idea of what the mate
is gonna look like and this represents
some sort of a transformation right oh
you trade rooks like is this really what
you wear the direction you want to go
but you're overthinking your up an
entire queen you're just gonna throw
your pieces at him and toward the end of
that game honest
too lazy to input all the moves
something very similar happened where
you kept shuffling your queen around
with check and you were getting
incredibly nervous like you couldn't
find the mate but it was like you kept
thinking the move had to be checked
whereas you could have just taken five
moves to bring a rook to the appropriate
square and set the checkmate up yeah I
think that's the problem I feel like if
something takes more than one or two
moves that it's gonna be too long I'm
gonna get myself in a bad position
that's the key I think that is the like
biggest realization and you're right in
most situations but when you're up a
queen you're free sailing like your
opponent can't do anything to you you
have 30 moves if you need 30 moves take
as many moves as you need but remember
you can use each of your extra pieces to
participate in the mate and it doesn't
have to be like a sequence of endless
checks that somehow magically morphs
into mate it's just all about setting
the target position you know
understanding which mating pattern
you're gonna hunt for and then just
going for it
you know what I'm saying yeah that makes
sense so for example let me just close
the board out instead of inputting like
the next 30 moves I'm actually just
gonna paste the position that occurred
at the toward the end of the game one
second and I'm going to re-invite you
okay here copy position so I know this
is a painful thing to talk about it's
not the most interesting but I think
this is like a must solve because it's
like it takes up so much of your time
yeah no I agree and you need to be able
to win these positions with like a
minute on the clock which is gonna be
something we're gonna be aiming for
there we go
a word set input the position I think I
sigh input in turbo Fisto it said
invalid position okay yeah I didn't know
I thought together with a missionary
position the turbo Fisto position was
was known but apparently not it's
powerful okay so this position occurred
in the illustrious game turbo Fisto
named neon 2020 and this is where you
were like dancing as if you were trying
to hunt down an elephant in the Safari
rather than checkmating a naked king
with an extra queen the real you took on
f7 but if you were to to be more
targeted and let's see who decided to
give the latter checkmate here and
basically track me at the King on the
eighth-ranked what move would you start
with I'd go right to f6 first right
because you can't escape through c5
because it's covered by Queen so he has
to go back exactly go ahead
I have to bring my King back now move
your queen in activate it and control as
many squares as possible there's there's
an intuitive square here that you should
just put your queen on okay so instead
of just delivering another useless check
I just wanna bring my queen up here to
e5 right
that's music to my ears you finally
understand this Khan like it doesn't
have to be checked after tick tick tick
forensic just slowly okay I can give you
a check big [ __ ] where do you go so now
I just want to I guess that's a good
question
so is there really a difference between
going F to G 2 or H 2 is one worse than
the other one better than the other nope
the zigzag method is a generally good
way of escaping these kinds of checks
guys with enough - and then g3 you can't
deliver a check again so okay yeah so
let's say I make some useless moves now
do the deed okay so now I'm just gonna
start my letter checkmate right so I
take this pawn first good so I have two
moves if I go to the background gets
made immediately I can go forwards and
now remember this this is where you're
like oh [ __ ]
can't deliver the latter Chatman and why
I screwed up but the reality is you can
just win his rook and then that ends the
game immediately which is and how can
you do that so instead of looking for
the checkmate I'm just looking to win
the rook then from this position which
you can do pretty easily yeah and that's
the first thing that I see when I'm
trying to save myself as much work as
possible are you looking for a fork oh
oh here no I see so I deliver this check
again that gives you an escape square
then okay and then I deliver this next
check here on e3 and then I'm taking it
right but you're looking only for a fork
you're forgetting about the skewer so
you're seeing like this relationship is
what you should see the king and the
rook on the same file okay so I'm just
doing it this way then yeah yes that's
exactly how you're doing it
okay so I guess I'm just looking for the
wrong things then you're yes alright
good knows it I was just saying I was
looking for the wrong thing I was
looking for the fork instead but I
realize it wasn't like a force to move
like you could just go back up right so
and this is this this is another thing
you can do is don't limit like sometimes
when you feel like there's a tactic in
the air in your mind you frame it so
like you think it's this particular kind
of tactic but you shouldn't do that like
you should open your mind up to whatever
tactic may present itself if you know
what I mean yeah you chuck so you're
like I can't see a fork I can't see if
where is the fork if you start looking
for other stuff you might find this
immediately and okay just for the sake
of completeness you know pack me up into
the coffin here another chance to score
a victory against the Grandmaster who
would have thought yeah I do love those
so does it matter this timing matter so
if I was in this position I'd
immediately just start snatching pawns
that's how that'd be how I'd do it yeah
but you wouldn't matter now I would just
go after the King I don't even know how
to describe that there's no technique
here intimating it's just
hunting him down in one of four hundred
and million ways use the rook in the
Queen to just slice up you can take all
of the spawns to anything works so yeah
the way I do it is just by taking pawn
yeah no I can't do that well you think
I'm gonna let you just run over me I'm
gonna use the last resources imide
asposed to make it as miserable as
possible of course also my job
shut this down
if you want to go after the pawns go
after the pawns I really can't find
checkmates with pawns that throws
everything up for me I see so this would
be how I'd play right here cut this off
sure and that's good that's good enough
so a 5 is forced and now you have
checkmate in two right it's yeah
checking me yes it works
mmm come down here no it's like this
reminds me it's like I've given you a I
don't know you're trying to play like a
suitor game with like a medieval torture
device or like a sable yeah I don't know
why I just can't really value it with
one
checkmate you're trying to approach the
King as if you're approaching like a
crime scene or something like creeping
up on it but just do it directly why are
you going through this angle rather than
for example C 2 or C 5 for example you
know what I'm saying yeah I see so this
will take some practice minutes it's
it's really drudgery to kind of like
work on this specifically but as long as
you understand the general concepts
you're so queen c6 is fine continue from
here it's not really that great though I
mean cuz then I still have to like make
extra moves here I still have to prep
this right so I have to come down here
anyway
a4 or b4 and I'm gonna just come here
yeah not bad
see that was already much better than
what happened against it so you know the
key here is not to settle on one like oh
I'm gonna win the pawns and then you
find yourself not winning the pawns and
you get nervous remember there's nothing
he can do you can take 30 moves if you
want as long as you know the general
direction
and you're making your pieces more
active I know that's not the most
satisfying thing to hear I mean we can
practice this specifically I could give
you a bunch of these positions and I
think we should do like a dedicated
segment to that but is that sort of
beginning to make a little bit more
sense yeah makes sense it's just another
weakness I can easily find checkmates
when the King's not around pawns of the
second he's shield I never know what to
do
yeah the peaceful in my chatter trying
to say like Oh huzzle wuzzle pub but
like this is not this doesn't come up in
puzzles very much this is nothing to do
with your tactical vision which I think
some people don't so your tactical
vision is actually really advanced and
you're able to see like combinations
this is like tech the only way I can
describe this is technique you know this
is a skill in and of itself finishing
off completely winning positions and
it's a skill that most people struggle
with at their own level so we will
definitely work on this I think this
might be your main weakness together
with the remnants of tunnel vision of
course hesitancy so let me give you a
choice I think we could for sort of the
grand finale you could jump back and we
could do the traditional we could
continue working on your technique I
mean if you're up for drudgery but a lot
of improvement I could give you a couple
of these positions we could play them
out and you could drill them or we could
leave that for a dedicated session
whatever you prefer so it tells me a few
of those bad boys real quick let me see
where that is and you know the people in
the shadows save boring boring or that's
exactly when most people quit chess
because they come to the point where
they realize that their weakness
corresponds with a part of the game they
hate the most or they find the most
boring and then they're like I don't
want to work on this [ __ ] like I don't
know I'm gonna fall asleep but you have
to if you want to get better there's
certain roadblocks you have to sort of
pass and you can't pass them without
doing like boring [ __ ] like 30 times in
a row so let me construct a couple of
like artificial positions of different
kinds and let's see if you can win them
playing as fast as possible on an
system I can't put clocks in but I want
to see how fast you can do it
so first position keep this analysis
board let's see if you can see the new
position in a second you're white you're
always gonna be white okay let's see if
it appears on your stream it has go
ahead I'm actually gonna
so I won't say any I won't give you a
needs unless you initiate it or like you
tell me what you're struggling with okay
I'll just this plate as fast as possible
then okay yeah sorry I just wanted it
just because I'd like to flex fair
enough man yeah I mean it's actually the
funny like people on stream were like
you're boring are the most ironic thing
ever because like of all the things they
could be doing like watching fascinating
YouTube videos they still dispatch much
so who's the joke on yeah take that
oh good good good but even with my
measly resources I can still get tough
for you yeah I think I can I can't break
this habit I think I know this is good
no this is what you have to do and in
certain positions you will have to take
the pawns first there's nothing wrong
with it remember what I said as long as
you play fast I don't care how many
moves it takes you what I care about is
the speed of the moves that you're
making which signals to me that you're
confident in the strategy you have
chosen flawless this is flaw this is
exactly oh I just for like that quote
Nova I can't yeah I can't keep it out of
my minds
branchy
okay good okay cool yeah this position
I'm pretty comfortable close what just
out of curiosity why aren't you cutting
off the King immediately on the side I
was just gonna well I wasn't gonna use
my knight I was gonna use the Queen King
checkmate that I'm used to I want you to
give me checkmate in two moves here okay
so then I do have to start with this
thing don't you do you could okay it's
made in Sioux and there's several ways
to deliver it actually well I think you
made a move I just don't see it oh you
gave me a check
yeah that works actually that's a nice
mate okay and then this one right here
is Ringo
so even though you might be familiar
with the Queen checkmate you're good
enough where you can think on your feet
this would be another checkmate mm-hmm
extreme that was perfect so you threaten
checkmate you separated my king from the
pawns you took them and you checkmated
me boom boom boom no problems and you
played fast okay lets me put on a
slightly different variance here I'm
gonna make this a little bit harder
surround you dim copy position okay
don't be scared there's gonna be a
something called a bishop here I think
you can worry you can you can win
despite its presence
and the improvement is already best this
is this is good this is gonna pay off
okay that's what I like to hear
don't do me like that stop you
don't mean this check cuz I can't take
that con right one thing I'll remind you
of use both of your pieces sometimes you
can get fixated on just trying to use
the queen but it's best when you use
them in concert queen does one thing
rook does the other thing they tear my
resources apart because I don't have any
of that yes so what I was looking at is
just going for the Queen rook checkmate
on the back rank but the bishop
obviously cuts that off at age eight
which you saw immediately right exactly
yeah I sniffed that out so this would
actually be a good time to go for some
points and and clearly the shrubbery
yeah exactly
okay I'm gonna try to go here but yeah
but I just deliver this yep no take
mm-hmm I'm gonna give you the most
devastating check in the world so just
go white I'll no reason to zigzag here
cuz then you're just gonna keep checking
that's actually highly inaccurate King G
- believe it or not really going G -
why's that
yeah just gettin ass [ __ ] with you
you kind of a [ __ ] up teacher man you
like make those students at your
training camp believe somewhat terrible
garbage and [ __ ] you're telling me okay
do you want me to tell you exactly the
prank that I pulled on some like really
strong players you'll understand it as
some yeah I mean hit me okay so let me
paste in a starting position comfy
position good by the way this is this
was good so what you did there is you
made that switch from okay I'm gonna
check me I'm on the seventh rank you
realize it's not that easy so you
realize which pawn is obstructing you
from doing that the f7 fun you go after
it okay so here it it here we go
true story so these are for context
people kids in the 2000 range so
extremely competent players and I was
able to convince that
basically what I told them at the
beginning of this camp they were Mike my
homeroom group so I taught them every
morning I basically said that throughout
my instruction I will throw in five or
seven lies so I'll like blunder Mike we
don't act on purpose and and pretend
like that's ingenious move and if they
like catch it I do ten push-ups push-ups
or something and if they don't catch it
it's the eternal shame on them so this
is called the night or variation in this
position I was able to convince a group
of like ten 2000s that Bishop f4 is the
latest rage in the chess world now sir
Charlie could you tell me why that is
the epitome of [ __ ] this is a [ __ ]
move with a pawn 45 exactly but it's not
that they didn't see this move I pretend
that this was a night sacrifice that was
carefully orchestrated by a Russian
Grand Master in a secret laboratory
somewhere underneath 30,000 underneath
30,000 feet underneath Moscow and
White's idea was to quickly castle I'm
very good at dressing up ideas that have
nothing to do with the reality of some
sort of genius concept and this is all
bs black is just up a piece and there's
literally nothing to show for it really
no you really do about this even what do
you mean there's no there's no recovery
here you just kind of [ __ ] your students
that may have believed it
no I mean eventually I revealed it IRA I
would never do I would never make them
go out into tournaments and play this I
mean I'd have like people it's pretty
I'd have people with tridents like out
my door in that case but no of course I
read it okay we had like a group of
expert indigo children here whatever
they're called the super geniuses
playing [ __ ] moves from you right
exactly I've sent them out at the
tournament's but the reality is part of
the reason I do some things things like
that is number one to make sure like the
kids especially are paying attention and
like that they ultimately believe in
their own was because in real chess
bluffing which I joke about this but
actual bluffing is a huge thing that
some grandmasters do they'll make a [ __ ]
move and you know they'll put on a
certain face and kids especially who
might be very talented and capable of
beating them will believe them they
won't make the refuting move because
they'll literally think oh this is a
grandmaster he must have seen it so I'm
kind of arming them with that confidence
to to call even strong players out of
their [ __ ] have you ever been
blocked by a really strong player
um plenty of times I've been left in
many many different ways it happens more
when like the younger you are it doesn't
even this that's one of those things in
chess that is I think age-related you
know once they became with GMI it's much
much harder to do that now but looking
through my games I can definitely find a
lot of examples of that
we're like shitty opening that someone
plays and because he's good you you
assumed that it was some sort of deep
preparation kind of like this right but
yeah definitely psychology of that kind
huge element of chess like facial
expressions even the way someone looks
at you massive impact on on you move you
can't help me like you look at your
opponent it's cool and you can just if
you're not experienced like you can be
swayed in ways that even you might not
recognize so anyways sorry sorry to drop
out about this that's each and every I
think everybody has disowned me no I'm
hopeless okay um let's me let's do one
or two more very good because I think
you're on a roll here
and it feels good sir how evil and on
the insulin okay there's something
you've kept hidden for a while oh yeah
this is deepest and darkest cabinet of
[ __ ]
that's shifts to the corner and a night
let's raise significantly raise the
level of difficulty and see how you
tackle this and ooh there we go
sorry try that again copy position paste
there we go okay so you're you're still
up a queen so you're good it's just that
now you only have like I have three
pawns for I'll be both of a pair of
knights
so horror force you might at some point
have to involve your king as well but I
don't think that's gonna be necessary if
you play this right
and no I'm not bluffing by saying this
is hard this is like actually the
hardest one we've done so far
I'm overthinking it nice good move
attacking my opponent it always starts
by introducing weaknesses in my pawn
shell I'm gonna try to keep it and this
is what I want you to understand the
Queen is such a mobile piece I want you
to find the next move correctly like you
have a way to get this f7 pawn yeah it's
right here
exactly see seeing that long-range Queen
move and once you rupture the initial
pawn shell the rest is essentially
history
only I can tell you how much that
particular motion well did I make them I
made that move us yeah how much that
particular motion the vintage turbo fest
still like hovering over a square almost
releasing the mouse and then bringing
the piece back to its initial Square
when the move you're about to make is
the correct one I am like dying in agony
on the inside does that happen often
well you do have checkmate in two moves
here believe it or not a beautiful
checkmate really a very elegant idea but
the best thing is why didn't you go for
Queen f7 just out of curiosity I just
thought maybe they'd get into a series
of the perpetual moves or something cuz
I come here you just drop King back I
don't have this pin on the knight
anymore that's okay you can win just win
my pawn though when my mark with your
knight that'll make your job so much
easier by the way the checkmate was
Queen a5 check and made on f7 okay the
other thing I was just looking at was
exploiting the pin which was bringing
Knight to e4 but I didn't see anything
to go with that so I assumed that wasn't
it yeah I mean you could also trait you
could also just trade nights and and
simplify into a man game that you know
very well that's also possible you see
how many different techniques there
anyways finish me off here
okay so then it's just bringing this
over here you're taking with the Millia
and then it's coming just basically yeah
just here
whoa that's a really nice move whoa Wow
well [ __ ] Jesus I can't believe that did
you think the knight was defending that
square did you not notice my king
I actually just didn't even think about
it to be honest it's okay you were just
seeing if I'm on my toes that's what it
was
god damn it this is everything yeah this
is a situation that can be tough because
like you don't see this like where
exactly do you go here the Queen needs
to be the leader here like your knight
is currently in the Queen's away the
Queen needs to be on f5 not the knight
yeah that's why I was thinking each six
then yeah sure that's good I would
centralize it normally I like to keep
the knight centralized for example
ninety four would be the best move so
the reason why is it increases the
chances for a fork for example if I stop
you from going to f5 what forking move
do you have now
Redemption time yeah I just come over to
f3 doesn't for it cuz you can just no
it's a yeah yeah Fork is perhaps that's
the wrong way to call it f3 and then
take c3 and the rest is history you can
just check mate with a queen or you can
check me with the queen in the night so
by and large you're getting better
already so you see a couple of things
here the first is this crack in the pawn
chain that you can introduce after which
everything becomes easy but don't fear
like a repetition or something - like an
actual draw by repetition is when the
same position repeats itself three times
you can't accidentally stumble into that
like unless something like especially
when you're up a queen you know what I'm
saying mmm-hmm so you almost need you
almost need to reach a stage in these
end games or your hands do the playing
like you're here well send a year you
and I was gonna rephrase that by saying
you're playing with your hands but
essentially your brain is supplying the
general high-level idea but you're not
like rethinking on an every move if you
know what I mean it's like in your
subconscious basically come get you and
that's ultimately what we're aiming for
so how do you feel in in this regard I
know it's it's not a lot but this is a
hard thing to do for long stretches of
time yeah I think it's just something I
need to work on more I see it the better
I'll get at it over time I agree and
yeah there's already a serious
improvement
[Music]
you
[Music]